okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is another episode and
our long-running effort to design
chemical computation functionality for
the upcoming version Wolff language by
the way I had reported I know who's
somebody from p.m. project management
here yes okay so I reported like five
times this fact that there's a period at
the end of that one hundred and fifty
percent thing right can you make sure
that gets reported to the front end
group say okay let's get going here so
we haven't talked about pattern molecule
have we no we haven't I think it's a
weird name I think it should be a
molecule pattern I have no objection to
that I was where I was using query
molecule but I was told that that was
not so good so I can use an old
flattering well let me understand what
it is and what sense is it a pattern so
essentially it just it has the same
structure as a molecule but it doesn't
do any of the checks necessary for for
chemical to make sure it's a valid
chemical so essentially it wants to get
used in functions like molecule position
or molecule clot it doesn't have any
formatting values at the moment that is
something we should talk about so this
is a molecule that is I mean if I make
that into a pure molecule here right
um somebody wants you want to switch off
your video thank you some if we make
those your pure molecule in that
particular case it will work correct yes
okay so let's say I add to this a
tungsten okay now that didn't work but
it produced something what does that
produce it produces a thing that isn't
actually a hung together molecule
correct right it's a disconnected
structure okay so what's wrong with Y is
patterned molecule not just molecule so
one thing that you can do in a pattern
molecule that you can't do in a regular
molecule you could say you could mark an
atom as being aromatic you can mark an
atom as having a partial calculated
partial charge within a particular range
you could you could say that it has
these are things that you can't do in a
molecule because you're being vague
about I mean in the in your pattern case
you want to be vague here rather than
being specific that it's oxygen you want
to say something less specific is that
correct right you could use alternatives
or see okay fine but I don't understand
why that isn't just molecule you know
why it isn't just something like this
okay and it's just a molecule right
right
so at that point let's assume we have
assume we have Michael here yes/no video
do we have Bob here yes should be here
perhaps here okay why would Michael
listed as being in this meeting when he
isn't here the first move - today - Bob
can join us what is a bubble Michael
okay whatever
but but as you can see here here's the
common ooh he's using as far as a
substructure here for a functional group
so it's not your molecule is this only
popover molecule right and so it could
be possible to use of not the molecule
ahead to represent a molecule pattern
there would just have to be checks to
see whether it's a pattern or not before
I try and do any of the stuff that I've
so there would have to be a quick check
to say are you a pattern or are you a
regular molecules and to see which code
paths to go down so so using a separate
head made it easier for me in writing
the functions but it's not it's not
absolutely necessary right so it's wrong
for users you know and besides the the
pattern itself as a symbol is only it
basically provides a handle to the
pattern by which you can use it in a
back reference an underscore by it you
know blank by itself is a pattern but it
doesn't require the wrapper pattern
around it no certainly doesn't I mean in
other words I think what we need is
something where there is a display form
for this right so for certain really
simple cases a display making a display
will be very easy for cert for others it
just comes out like this and everybody's
happy right and so we have the function
molecule Q which up until now only will
only give true if something is a valid
well I think I think it's the wrong name
for that I think it should be something
like what is the real criterion for a
molecule being a validated molecule so
to speak excuses it can be made no I
don't believe you we don't necessarily
know that do we do know that it has to
have the valence has to be satisfied
within the standard valence rules
shouldn't have any missing hydrogen's on
well actually hydrogen is a different
issue but it definitely does not have to
be something that's makeable right so I
mean is it is it something like
structural molecule Q or something
if molecule Q doesn't cut it I'm sorry
it just doesn't make any sense because
in addition to that we mean you know we
may represent these cluster type things
as a molecule you know the things where
there are multiple disconnected pieces
and so on in a molecule am I making
sense
yes right so it doesn't make sense to
call it molecule Q it's slightly an
abuse of things to call this molecule
right but it's okay but so what we need
to do is to say what is the aspect of
this thing that makes it valid in the
sense what I'm saying the structural Q
would be good as long as it's understood
that it's strictly the topology the two
dimensional structure are not a 3d
structure well okay so give me a better
chemical name for this what what is the
what is the attributes that the thing
has that makes it valid in the sense
valence Q something like that okay so
what will be a valence balanced I don't
know whether that makes sense I mean
right I mean so
so aside from the name the the the way
that the reason that this function is so
necessary I mean what it I mean what it
really tells the user is that this has
passed all of the checks and we've week
you can use this molecule in any
function and it it will behave like a
like a Wolfram language molecule you
know that's the slippery slope because
there's going to be functions but you
can't do that for whatever reason
because the molecule was too big because
it has the wrong atoms in it bla bla bla
bla bla so it's it isn't the case that
this is a check that everything is going
to work this is a check that the
molecule is not obviously sort of
non-functional so to speak but what's a
positively charged ions right you
support also as a molecule then it's not
balanced anymore
right so that means so in that case it's
not that it's so that I'm not the
biggest fan of balance no okay fine so
tell me what is right so I mean to go
super simple would be to give it a sub
value that is just valid Q no that won't
work
can't do that what do you mean you mean
molecule blah blah blah are valid that's
that that's a bad idea but we need some
function that checks the molecule and
decides whether it is a blah molecule I
mean we could say structurally I don't
know whether you know structurally valid
Q but that that sounds wrong and it's
too general it's too general it's not
referring just to a molecule
um all right we're gonna have to come
back to this right so now I wish Michael
would have had something useful to say
about this I think because I think there
are other places in the system where we
have similar kinds of things okay again
can you tell me if you're explaining to
somebody in chemistry speak you know
what is this thing checking for what
would you say so I would say it's
checking for chemical validity that the
that the the molecule you've entered
meets the the generally agreed upon
rules of chemical validity and that that
is that that you don't have ten bonds to
carbon that you don't have four bonds to
nitrogen with no charge those are the
areas where it's really going to come up
come up to users as why why why isn't
this molecule I entered valid mark is
invalid just six for contradictions so
it's moment well so you're saying
chemical a valid Q essentially yes
chemically valid q and in the reference
page we could give the details of what
that means yeah and it may be that it
has a second argument that will define
the fine could have various
possibilities for what what's being done
there Jason put yourself on the Fillies
so you could say strict or fuzzy you so
you can you can see I am so you can just
actually not bad fine
and so then so then it would by default
or then the single argument form of a
return false on a pattern and then you
with a second argument like yeah you can
make it more strict
say I only want to balance all the nine
should be balanced
yes this seems reasonable to me and in
some cases where you can have you know a
single molecule versus clusters versus
whatever else all right let's keep going
I like that that name for now
okay what is this about so molecule
position so we go to molecule hip for
goodness sake Jason please find a way to
get a headset that doesn't have too much
gain okay in any case
you
okay so normally this would just be icy
so this is nice now why can this here oh
it has to be six items I was thinking
about this when I was writing this up
that one could omit the atoms list and
just as long as the indices of
referenced in the list of bonds forms a
we could just take the version of this
would be repeated blank coma six is that
right I forget the syntax are repeated
six has to be inside of a list to be
exactly six care otherwise that would do
it
okay all right okay fine so now if I go
like this splosh why is that why didn't
that work so let's see so I didn't set
up a pattern to match on repeat it yeah
so we need that okay I mean it should
just be a pattern should appear generic
pattern right so with a lot of these I
have to hard code the the patterns
because I need to because I need to
build up a library object out of it that
sounds like a bad idea it's not using
the the Wolfram language pattern matcher
except in certain cases okay so that
seems like a nightmare for testing who
started testing lists so Sean I've been
talking with with Sean Clark I've been
making an extensive test suite as I as I
do this but that particular issue of
Wolfram language patterns that are not
supported first of all you know you have
to have reasonable messages about it and
second of all it seems like you need a
fallback mechanism where you go through
the general pattern system
but let's keep going molecule position
seems now what is it exactly returning
it's returning so there are two benzene
rings and it is at those positions and
those are the referenced so if these
things were named if that was an
association no how do we deal with named
elements in a molecule so you're allowed
to reference the elements by their name
but we don't return the name we the
canonical form is always the the indices
the index so position always returns
indices yes ok so what's interesting
here is yeah so I mean that position is
rather different from our usual position
because it's not succession of levels
that's a list of positions right which
is where initially I was calling this
fine molecule substructure because
specifically because it doesn't there's
the concept of levels here doesn't
doesn't apply in general like so yeah it
has the different syntax than or
different return types and the position
and why did we change it to molecule
position well let's see we we didn't
like find molecule substructure it was
too it was too wordy so this is actually
molecule extract if I'm not mistaken
right or is that does extract have
different or is know maybe this is
molecule molecule part would usually
give this as a list of elements right if
it was just part if I had here
ABC part you know 2 1 1 for example that
would give me a list right so molecule
part is giving me a molecule of those
sub elements yeah what do we do for
subgraphs what do we do what is the
analog of this for graphs controls say
something about that
Charles
hello Charles
strolls here sorry I was trying to help
Raja for his connection okay should I
repeat the question yes please okay
molecule part is extracting essentially
the subgraph with elements 2 4 5 from
the molecule I'm asking what is the
analogous function for graphs so we have
some sub graph which essentially allow
you to build a list of edges just give a
bunch of vertices so the analog of this
is this would be if FM was a graph I
could say sub graph of M comma 2 4 5
here that correct
right okay and so the extension here is
that if you give molecule part and then
a list and then give a list of lists you
can get back a lists of molecules which
I don't know if that's a common common
enough thing to want to do with graphs
in order for that to have been
implemented it's not on the
documentation for sub graph calls so is
sub graph list of elements part
specifications as the question here
listing specification well is no depend
because the vertex and it's a via list
so the kind of assembly careful on that
but is listable if you give a list of
vertices on the list of in this case
this molecule thing is if I what Jason
is saying is that if there's a list of
lists here it will return a list of
molecules your point is the actual label
of a vertex could be a list yes wait
okay fair enough that's a perfectly
reasonable argument so this is something
I was originally calling I was calling
it molecule extract but it was decided
that the the the differences between the
return and fer position and extract is
was different enough that we should
should go with part okay my question
here is yeah what is the analog of
maliki
infographs is there a graph position if
there was a graph position is this what
it should return so the Grove when you
find a subgraph in a graph how do you
return where the sub graph is well for
cough we build the sub graph so we
generate the actual result in half we
don't say this position no no I'm saying
if I if I want to find a sub graph in a
graph how do you specify where that sub
graph is suppose I've seen have been
with highlight graph yes but we don't
have you know canonical way to describe
the position of sub cough in it sub
graph has an argument structure to
describe what sub graph you are asking
I'm saying what's happening here is
we're saying given a a graph pattern
okay I want to know I mean one thing one
question would be returned the sub
graphs to me that match that pattern
right which is another thing you might
want here which is molecule cases and
the making sense yes it does okay so so
now in the case of sub graphs graph
cases would be a bunch of sub graphs but
graph position should be a specification
in the original graph of where those sub
graphs occur see what I'm saying but how
would you refer to those sub cough I
mean was disease why not when you
extract something from a graph but you
extract a sub graph let's look at the
sub graph function
so you also wanted some molecule in I
can't this this prototype doll has
broken documentation I don't know yet
okay okay so there it's given a bunch of
vertices right so that then returns the
actual sub graph right with all of its
connections it says pull out these
vertices and and there are no dangling
hairs is that correct in this and what
you mean by sub graph there's never
anything dangling that correct
did you understand what I'm saying we
are still in the donkey nutriment do you
say that in this documentation you
really graph this to find the graph
itself is defined that way you can't
have an edge without having a vertex
that it can vertices that it's connected
to fair enough so that's the definition
of graph okay on the other hand grabs
can have isolated vertices sure okay so
one is to for sub graph I mean as we
think about graph rewriting and things
like that the idea of a sub graph with
angling you know tentacles is is going
to be needed and that's similar to the
pattern molecule construct you have I
think in other words it says
well I don't know how somewhere it is
there is an edge but we're not saying
what it goes to and there's gonna be
lots of implicit edges in a pattern
molecule that we're not specifically not
not saying so that carpet that carbon
there that has two bonds is equivalent
to the third argument of sub cough there
where we take a pattern you can
hopefully say the right at age 1 , you
know long I'm sorry say that again even
the third usage case yeah right you can
have sort of one edge blank something in
that way subgraph let's see so I mean it
will it was the pattern can either a
vertex pattern so that's a blank arrow 3
right I see the case here right and
that's a that's an undirected graph
right so that goes both ways
right but I mean so that is similar to a
dangling end isn't it no I mean it is
it's just anything the blank is
obviously anything right but it's not
dangling because it matches whatever it
matches that actually exists so what
comes out is not dangling you know it's
just I thought it grabs that out of a
node yeah yeah it's just a two vertex
graph okay all right so let's take a
look now of what that means for so
you're saying the analog of subgraph is
what you are currently calling molecule
part is that a true statement yes what
is this in the literature of
computational chemistry is there a name
for this thing the substructure right
Jason right so the pattern I would call
a substructure and then I mean the
resulting thing so this is something we
haven't really fully mentioned but so
when we take the molecule part we find a
we extract those those vertices in the
second argument and then we can we will
also fill in any empty hairs before
returning it to you because we want to
return to you a full and valid
chemically valid molecule so although
one might not always want that you could
return a pattern as well great that yeah
that's a that's a very good point it's
not implemented yet but yeah okay all
right so so what you're saying
so you're saying what would happen if
instead of calling a molecule part one
called it molecule substructure so so
the name molecule substructure makes me
think that it's not just a function that
acts on a molecule and returns a a
molecule it would be let's see I mean so
to me molecule substructure could also
define the the patterns of anion resins
and verb yeah okay so the problem with
molecule part I mean it's two
mathematical to say anything like that
but that is what it is and but what
let's see molecule position is it better
to have the part position cases analog
even though it doesn't do exactly the
same thing
what do we think yeah
oh yes all of those things are common
operations that are done on a molecule
by a computational chemist
what should they be called I mean so so
we've got molecule part molecule
position molecule cases so do we all
agree that a molecule extract would just
be would be the wrong name instead of
molecule part I like molecule extract
but I've never been one to use extract
so I don't I don't I think it's kind of
crazy because you read it as molecule
extract and somebody's gonna think it's
some vanilla extract on your spice shelf
yeah and or extract like what's it
extract preserved when you do extract
you get something back of the same
structure part you usually don't I don't
follow Roger when you do extract of a
matrix or or a tensor or something like
that typically get back something of the
same structure why I mean it depends on
why you would where were dug down to in
the tree of course yeah but for an
arbitrary expression extract can cover
multiple levels and so on it can return
a list of of parts okay I have a
proposal okay my proposal is that we
call them things like molecular maybe
this is crazy this is probably crazy
because I what bothers me is that
absolutely
crazy because what's troubling to me is
molecule part it just seems 12 comments
about these molecule position just seems
very weird
whereas molecular position seems like it
is you know a more reasonable way to say
what we have so to me molecular instead
of molecule it makes it I don't know it
it makes it worrier I guess even though
I mean it makes it longer they don't
know that right and I don't know right
right right but I don't know that it's
um that it conveys more information I'm
I don't know I do what's that like a sub
molecule yes the sub molecule is just to
turn that nobody uses I think symbolic
you could fit here and I another instead
of position or instead of molecule
position I was originally wanting to or
one of their names I was playing around
with with substructure position but the
the point was made that it wasn't the
word sub structure without referring to
molecule is not going to work right that
it's it's too general and it would also
like to many other things gonna work
right off the table it's not gonna work
so that's what
yeah yes I mean right so molecule
position sub molecule cases doesn't
really work you could
as functional groups that you've won all
the functional groups and a and a nickel
tooth no no I understand what it would
do I did that word doesn't work okay
okay sorry
I have to say I think these are the
least ridiculous of the things I've seen
so far the problem that I have is
molecule part I don't know
I mean well molecule part to me sounds
like it's very specific to the first
argument whereas Molecular part sounds a
little too general although you know
would be referring to some part of its
first argument you know and I guess it
the name would grow on me as I used it
more it just sounds a little familiar
that's all this will be my first take on
what we should do with these um let's
keep going for right now that's among
boned patterns so atom list atom count
bond list von count were made kind of
while looking at at vertex lists and
vertex count edge lists edge count fine
fine
so if I just do a pure a simplicity
um I will get out okay what's the order
of those things oh I see that's the
number that's the position that they are
in there and those are the labels of
those particular atoms in the molecule
so that's essentially the the it just
gives you the the first argument of the
of the molecule right okay so atom count
if I make this atom count really why am
I not getting the the count of each
that's kind of Asst why is that even
useful wait what what were you expecting
count is expecting an association but
the number of carbons the number of this
number of that s not what graph that's
how I know what vertex count gives you I
mean knowing the number of atoms in your
molecule is is very useful oh it is okay
right I mean I mean just say anytime I'm
looping over the atoms or doing
something I've I I find that function to
be pretty useful myself okay what you
just proposed Steve and getting an
association back in the number of
carbons number of hydras etcetera itself
would also be very useful so let's go
Adam count that would be the analog of
counts for a list
yeah I'm not a decimal here accounts but
I will look at it yeah you know okay I
think it's
useful for bonds I think Adam counts
makes sense I think bond it's just you
want the list of bonds and there's no
bond count either as there no there is
sorry I that useful yes the bond count
is useful and I think bond counts would
also be useful and what would it give
you because it's because each bond is a
unique thing so what would bond counts
do because there's only gonna be one
bond between seven and eight for example
that's true okay I was expecting it to
return the number of single bonds number
of double bonds number triple bonds
number of aromatic bonds number of
dative bonds okay fine but then then
that would return then I suppose what we
would have to do there is to return
something like
you know it's a little weird something
like this I mean the other way to do it
I suppose would be to do something like
that that would be sort of conceptually
correct if a little messy you agreed
agreed for Adam counts then Adam counts
is not a problem well the only question
for Adam counts as well the left hand
side is Adam see or just see yeah yeah
right now would apply to Adam list as
well I mean the eye canonicalize your
molecule to always have a list of Adam
objects but but if you of isotopes
indicated don't we have the possibility
of having to decorate those Adam things
right and so make the decision that when
you ask for the Adam list return the
string only if it's if it's simple and
if it's not then you return the Adam
object right now it always returns the
Adam object well we can give another
argument to Adam list the can determine
whether that's what it does I mean most
of the time you're just gonna have
string names for elements right right I
mean when a user enters a molecule there
that's what they would do they would
expect them to type see Oh F but I can
honest it to this to always have Adam
see I think it should be Adam see by
default formatting list let's talk about
this in ring false Freight so so that
calls so that's one of the so that's
essentially how you you enter an Adam
pattern is the first and Adam would take
the first argument telling you what type
of Adam it is and then everything after
that is its rules what kind of things
are in that let's see so so when you're
making a chemically valid molecule the
the list of rules would include formal
charge mass number or unpaired electron
count and possibly another one this in
ring which is a very strange part of
speech and so on so so then these are
various
then when you make a pattern molecule it
can have I don't like in ring because
it's a different form it would be
something like ring element or something
or ring atoms I click or a cyclic would
be more conventional okay so it's a it's
a boolean property so it's a property
that you can ask I understand
mean you can ask you could ask whether
how can you ask so you could do molecule
value of a molecule comma in ring and
you'll get the list you'll get a list of
true/false the length of a list of atoms
or you could ask it for a particular
atom you can ask
that's what molecule value gives you I
would say that that would be something
like at a map if that's what that's
doing if it's giving you something for
every element for every atom and the
thing mapping of all of them right so
molecule value is there to give you
property values of the molecule and for
properties of atoms that depend on the
molecule I was using a molecule value
for that as well so say you want yeah
okay fine but so that's saying that in
the case where it is a atom property
rather than a molecule property then
you're doing the auto and you
automatically mapping over the atoms in
the molecule is that right right I use
so the way I haven't constructed there a
property can have a qualifier just like
an entity property and so the property
quality alright fire in this case is
atoms the string atoms so you could ask
for the month or a molecule property
formal charge comma atoms go to one two
three that's really that that mapping
over does it ever need to look at it
surrounding right so most of these
properties it it depends on the rest of
the molecule there there is only a small
subset of the atom properties that are
independent of the molecule
like what's that it means it's not map
like yes you're not extracting the atoms
together that's correct
so in this case this in ring I really do
not like that okay um I mean the right
way to say it is when you say it is
cyclic what's the it it's not means it's
part it's part of a cycle you know ring
but I understand but I'm saying when you
say cyclic I don't think that the term
you know you don't say oh that's a
cyclic atom you say this part of the
molecule is cyclic right
right the atom is in a cyclic
environment strictly speaking the atom
itself is not cyclic but its environment
is cyclic
as opposed to a cyclic yeah I understand
is it always a ring that it's in how can
it be another thing a little ring
chemists we talk about rings and then
graph theory
awesome cycles yeah but in propane for
example the three carbons are all
acyclic sure well I mean so one could
call it ring element or something that
sounds a bit wrong because it's I mean
don't a bit algebra like a ring element
yes I don't like that name I mean again
what are the other names you were
telling me right so so you can ask for
the total total bonds or talk about the
other properties of an atom who said
formal charge is one of the properties
right so then mass number yeah okay fine
so there's things like formal charge
mass number okay so in with those parts
of speech what would be the analogue
that will tell you whether it's in a
cyclic environment or not right and I
understand it's I think that's very
obscure to say cyclic environment or is
it not you tell me for a computational
chemist it's a bit long way to do which
is say cyclic or a cyclic but the it
isn't look it's not the atom but is you
say this carbon is acyclic do you say
that I don't think you do I think you
say about the whole molecule
actually I think they do they would
refer to an acyclic carbon as opposed to
a cyclic carbon within a molecule okay
we gotta have another name in ring
doesn't cut it okay I think we agree
with you there but we're struggling with
a better name right I mean are there
other things that sort of allows you to
- so this one reach it out and look at
the connectivity structure around or
that but other ways that you give that
like little constraints like that so in
it for a pattern like I like this I mean
you can as you can specify the the
partial charge which is something that
needs the rest of the structure in order
to compute it Roger is asking something
which doesn't on the face of it which
which is like
you know it's asking for other graph
theoretic properties which there could
be many I mean this could be one you
know a one-level in a dendrimer or
something and it knows that it's in this
dendrimer and far away from um you know
maybe you call that backbone chain
something and maybe you want to say I
only want the carbons in the backbone
chain okay that's a good example it
would apply to a few fields of chemistry
such as proteins nucleic acids polymers
okay but what about things know cyclic
compound true or false right so that
mean that element is part of a cyclic
compound or not
mocchi the word compound has trouble in
chemistry yeah the whole molecule can be
called cyclic or acyclic if it has any
ring in it at all specific atoms within
the molecule in my experience they've
been referred to as either cyclic or
acyclic also whether or not they are in
a ring so I mean determined by whether
or not they're in a ring yes
sounder from our live stream suggests
relative position arrow cyclic or not I
don't think that's quite right so let's
see so we have various count properties
and so there could be ring count so the
number of rings that this atom is in
that's nice
and that would just be zero if it isn't
in a ring right through true the actual
count of ring so Jason is that's
strictly unambiguous a number of rings I
mean there's I mean we have a particular
algorithm for finding the smallest
subset of smallest rings exactly exactly
and we we follow that and it would have
to be that and it would just be the the
count of the membership in those rings
and at that set of rings it seems a
little oops well I don't know you tell
me whether that's a it's not obscure a
it's just part of computational
chemistry this was recognized thirty
years ago the smallest set of smallest
rings ring count which is zero if the
thing is on a non ring mm-hmm don't go
baby
what right they the smallest set of
smaller strings in the cycle basis I see
that in the code is there a recycle
basis for graphs yeah what do you call
it
mm-hmm and remember no child let's see
cyclic basis I think donation here we
should figure that out because we have
find fundamental cycles right that's
actually that no I'll give you the basis
I look for that so then if we have the
property is ring count it could be zero
it could be greater than zero or it
could be a number you're suggesting it
would actually be greater than zero like
that right I mean you can do that with
formal charge or or any of the other
atom properties that I have set up
I mean just not just one ring right
right so so the this is all I mean I
started out just using the the smarts
language the this regex for four
molecule patterns and they're one of the
things that you can set in a smart
string is the number of rings that
something is in do you have a different
ring we can you can you distinguish if
it's a benzene ring and automatic ring
or something else also then you have to
make a you have to make a pattern to
cover the whole ring at that point okay
so I'm sorry so you're saying the ring
word isn't the right thing or what
nitrogen oxygen at that point you make a
more complicated pattern than just an
atom right so so so this we're talking
about a pattern for an atom and you
would say what about just calling this
ring member arrow true or false that's
good that's good for that if you wanted
the bridgehead carbon though in other
words an atom that was in two rings at
the same time and there are two atoms
like that and the example immediately
above Mosher on our live stream
suggested ring member right around the
saw the message so good multiple minds
think alike okay but you're saying if
you actually wanted see to me it seems
like it's going to be obscure this ring
count thing is going to be kind of
obscure rate agreed so I mean
conceivably you could have a hack of
having the right hand side of ring
member be a number
let's move on I think we've got a
reasonable resolution for this so far
let's see and so the bottom one more
point when you do atom list as a
convenience you can give a rule as the
second argument pattern goes to property
and if it's an atom property then we
will return the list of values so we
support you do you support smarts
smiles spit them all so let's see so for
an atom you can give a smarts pattern as
an as an atom right no okay
so this is analogous to regular
expression of blah blah blah right this
thing here yep
and I probably suggested this in a
previous meeting that we actually have
this sum I mean what's the possibility I
see I mean if if we were to say so this
thing here turns into a molecule one of
our pattern molecules is that true or
does it does it just sit there as a none
evaluated sort of smart string it just
sits there I let's see I wouldn't mind
in the future being able to do a to
convert it but at the moment I have not
written that up okay so if you were to
convert it this could be molecular
pattern and be perfectly happy and and
you could give us a second argument what
kind of you know there's a smarts
molecular pattern but it could default
to that so you're saying I not have
smarts pattern as ahead that's what I'm
saying but just have molecular pattern
of you know C equals o or something and
then that would be the same as saying
that comma
small possibly won't even want something
like this Smart's arrow that sure so in
this case I mean the way that a molecule
if you give it just a string it will try
and see if it's a smile string right
away and so in this case molecular
pattern could do that as well it could
just say you've given me a string and I
I assume it's a smarts yeah exactly
that's what I'm suggesting yes exactly
so that would be the default but were we
to use some other future kind of string
it might be a second argument or it
might be in this form here so go ahead
so earlier on I thought that we were
talking about moving away from having a
molecular pattern head yes but the point
is that you need some way of taking your
string because that string means
something different doesn't it in the
molecule case in the molecular pattern
case absolutely explain the difference
so it is so let's see so as a smile
string that carbons specifically has two
hydrogen's but as a pattern it has two
hairs so to speak or yeah in two hairs
then those two errors could be could be
bonded to one carbon so you could be
have two double bonds on either side or
it could so you could make a molecule
that is C equals C equals o to use the
and it would match on that smarts
pattern okay so I mean to me growth
pattern is going to end up being
something a bit similar to this it's
going to be a you know a we don't have
it yet but it's going to be some kind of
hairy object is it not hairy in the
sense that it has dangling hairs that
are edges without a vertex at the other
end of them is that right
Charles Rocha yeah I mean there will be
imperfect but but you don't care what it
is well I think the specification I
guess here right that what you mean even
that's what I mean yes it is like any
like in any vertex you know regions
underscore for right right I mean your
molecular pattern if I'm not mistaken
could equally well so I'm a little
confused by this is it the case that
molecular pattern has some bonds without
anything up there with blank essentially
at the other end or does it have
something different in it
it simply omits them in this case here
of the C double bond o the the hairs
could be two single bonds or it could be
one double bond and there they're
different but the pattern C double bond
o would match to either of those cases
either of those situations
I'm a little confused is it just the
analogy does the analogy hold that a
graph pattern would be a graph with I
mean it could be a graph with certain
vertices being given as blank am I
making sense so will be something like
yeah but but in a way if you do the
analog or graph here there's sort of
other properties okay so we have
different kinds of edges okay and that
would be modeled as a property you know
like you can have in all kinds of other
context is this okay so something like
this right
well that's doing goofy thing because
that's treating blank as a literal
vertex right right yes okay so what I'm
saying here is maybe there should be a
graph pattern in which the blank here
means essentially a half I mean we use
it as a graph pattern already throughout
wherever you select something you
specify properties we use graph patterns
patterns as a you don't use come you
don't use actual graphs as the graph
button do you just use them because we
have we can talk about the objects
themselves but what I could imagine that
you want you know if you if you have
sort of more advanced functionalities to
make it substantially simpler to also
include properties and when you want to
match things because it's done right
older the simple structural notion of a
graph is there but other properties
really matters you know like in
chemistry we really care that it's a
carbon versus an oxygen right well so my
my provisional conclusion would be that
molecular pattern is essentially a
simple syntactic wrapper which happens
to take in smarts but it also is a way
of specifying that things have hairs on
the end so to speak
does that make sense to people
I think it does to me okay all right
okay let's keep going
maximum common sub structure and so this
is a case where it would be desirable to
actually return a molecule pattern
object with a list of atoms and bonds
but at the moment the the library I have
returns a
Smart's pattern well that's a mess so
but can't you turn that into yeah okay
so you'd have to decode that as a marker
ocular pattern right and that is
definitely in the in the plans okay
can we do that with strengths can we go
from a reg X to a string expression in
all cases no no we don't have that
capability at this time you know we I
mean an order we guarantee that it's
possible right and that may still be the
case with smarts versus a Wolfram
language molecule so that was the case
is that what you returned here is
molecular pattern of that string or the
smart string okay yeah and the string
doesn't resolve right but in this case
in this case it would actually be fairly
easy to no fun if it can resolve it does
resolve but they don't resolve it just
stays there as a smart string yeah okay
okay this maximum common sub structure
so weird I mean some attraction in the
community is that you know it has no it
doesn't say anything about chemistry in
the name
Chloe should it be max common sub
structure I don't know how that's
consistent with other things or not I
think max is consistent with other
usages within the language like max
iterations yeah like that's what I think
too
okay so this is where you're doing the
selector as well as the oh boy this is
pretty funky because in the case of
entity value for example that third
argument is not a selector argument
right so so in an entity value call the
the property in the qualifier think it's
subsumed and there would be an entity
property mass number comma atoms goes to
seven and you don't have this is crazy
that is analogous to nothing okay so
I'll take that out it really doesn't
make any sense so so I came up with a
function called a register molecule
property that would allow a user to
register a property with their own name
if they wanted to use the why what can't
they just do the assignment I mean I
know it's dumb why can't they just make
a function that does what they want yeah
that makes the most sense then you know
don't take that part oh okay what's this
thing here this here this here I don't
understand why this isn't molecule value
of molecular part of M comma 7 : mass
number do you get what I'm saying
well so so molecular part as discussed
above what evaluates so there would have
to be a different what what so what if
it evaluate what's wrong with that
so lots of the the properties of the
atom would change if you took it out of
the molecule what a mess because we
can't have something which is both
yeah I understand but we can't have two
different ways to refer to that atom
because one way of referring to that
atom is to say molecular part of M comma
7 right and that appears to extract that
molecule that atom basically
whereas this is the in situ version of
that asking about
you
I mean if you're gonna do that I would
have thought you have to say molecular
property
and then you've got to be able to say em
and then you've got to be able to give
the part specification seven comma mass
number well maybe that second argument
is optional did you get what I'm saying
yes defaulting to the whole molecule yes
and if we wanted to do something based
on three atoms in the molecule it would
be a list of those three atoms for the
second argument yes it would but I don't
know whether it's listable by default
whether it's some yes that's another
good point whether it's an aggregated
thing I mean you might want to either of
those exactly
I can see uses for both so the function
that you have here molecular property
that would return the property value
that is correct yeah okay all right I
I'm changing my mind about what that
should be called okay okay so let's say
it's called molecular value and then
then there's the question of the
stability of that second argument and
and then also does the part
specification go in the second argument
cuz oftentimes you're going to be
calling molecular value M and then just
a property name I know I know we just
said it's an optional second argument
okay so that would also work and that
will be equivalent to presumably this so
I'm saying we need other examples of
what the second argument I mean what the
what the property argument to my killer
value can be the other thing we could do
here is have a decorator of some kind
for this but you're saying that
molecular part which is the most obvious
thing to use here can't work
yeah because that takes that ya xc2
would that be appropriate you know it
takes it out of the molecule and we
don't want to do that and I'm also I
would also argue at this point that
molecular value is not list of all if
you want a list of all you'll just have
to map it over I agree we hold on what
it's not list of all over these elements
because you might want the aggregated
some property here that is aggregated
that some weird chiral property you've
got three atoms you want to know whether
it they make a I don't know what all you
know all your weird a Carol Center or
not yeah we shouldn't those properties
be exclusive I mean what what property
would apply to one atom and then two to
three atoms you want the mass of those
three atoms automatically the total mass
or that the net partial charge something
like that see to me that seems that you
would just apply total at the end you I
am super late for something else so
let's let's stop here I think this is
going in a reasonable direction I don't
think we necessarily solve this but
we've got to see is what the possible
names here can be okay make sense okay
yes I'm sure but I'm just beaming on day
meetings I'm not the PM of the project
but I was assigned for the day stretch
meeting okay okay who am i selling I'll
send this back to Jason then I thought
um okay okay I'm not saving this
notebook this is just being saved so I'm
just sending this back to you guys okay
on the live stream we are actually going
to another live streamed meeting so you
are welcome to join that and thanks
everybody and when we go
till soon bye right right